at some point growing up my vision
changed and slowly I stopped being able
to see past about
this far in front of my face basically
anything past like 10 inches in front of
my eyes
is blurry So eventually I got glasses
and with them my world turns from this
to this
this whole experience as inconvenient as
it is is more widespread than it's ever
been myopia myopia am I saying it might
arise in short-sightedness the
researchers actually called it an
epidemic but they're still trying to
figure out why this is rates of myopia
or nearsightedness or needing glasses to
see things far away have been rising for
decades in the US where I live just 25
percent of people were myopic in 1971.
by 2004 that number was up to 42 percent
and if current trends continue it's
estimated that half of the world's
population will be myopic by 2050. in
Hong Kong Singapore Taiwan and South
Korea rates are already a lot higher
than that and a growing portion have
high myopia which The Who categorizes as
a prescription stronger than -5 that
puts them at risk of losing their sight
one day for decades researchers thought
that whether or not you needed glasses
was just a matter of genetics and it
partly is having one myopic parent
doubles your odds of being nearsighted
and and having two increases the odds
five-fold but human genetics don't
change this fast the abruptness of this
increase suggests that this change is
environmental something about the way we
live today is making it harder and
harder for people to see at a distance
so what could it be
most people are born with eyes that are
too short from front to back in this
shape the lens focuses images behind the
retina that's the light sensitive tissue
at the back of the eye that makes the
eye hyperopic or farsighted blurry up
close and clear from far away but as we
grow up our eyes grow too until they
reach a spherical shape in this shape
the lens focuses light directly onto the
retina and produces a clear image but
sometimes the eye keeps growing longer
in this shape the lens can focus up
close images onto the retina but at a
distance images focus at a point in
front of the retina making distance
vision blurry so all of us with myopia
just have eyeballs that have grown too
long the eye does not look like a
basketball anymore it looks more like a
rugby ball that's Chiang Mai saw she's a
myopia epidemiologist and physician in
Singapore it is a lifelong disease so
once you're myopic it doesn't regress so
what's making more and more people's
eyes grow longer than they should the
evidence points to the way we spend time
in childhood and Adolescence that's when
our eyes grow fastest so it's when most
people's myopia develops and then
stabilizes though it can develop later
if you abuse your vision enough two
factors in particular have the biggest
influence near work or the time that we
spend looking at things up close and how
much time we spend indoors in a healthy
eye muscles have to squeeze the lens in
order to focus up close images onto the
retina so some experts theorize that if
your eyes grow up straining to look at
things up close a lot of the time
they'll just grow longer to reduce that
strain but the evidence on this
explanation is mixed the stronger
explanation is time spent indoors
exposure to Bright outdoor light
stimulates the production of dopamine in
the retina this neurotransmitter
regulates the eye's growth without
enough dopamine the eye doesn't know
when to stop growing and indoors it's
hard to get enough the light from the
sun has up to a hundred thousand lakhs
on a sunny day whereas in a room the
light levels generally and there are
only about two to three hundred laps but
between electronic devices and early
emphasis on academics I experts believe
that children today are growing up with
a combination of too little daylight and
too much time doing things up close and
nowhere is that more apparent than an
East and Southeast Asia children in Asia
are not spending that amount of time
outside this could possibly be because
of the education system it's become much
more competitive the children have a lot
more homework they attend tuition
centers and they spend more time reading
and writing kneading glasses or contacts
to see for the rest of your life is
obviously inconvenient but in the long
term the consequences of that distorted
eyeball shape can become serious
University of Houston professor of
Optometry Mark bolomore explained this
to me you know you're born with a finite
amount of tissue that make up the
various coats of your eyeball excessive
elongation of that quite simply places
additional stress on those structures
the retina has been stretched so much
that starts to break and then sort of
peel off like a an old piece of paint
the longer those eye structures are
stretched the higher the risk of
disorders like myopic macular
degeneration retinal detachment glaucoma
and cataracts so we're finding this
almost linear relationship between the
amount of myopia and the risks into your
vision later in life we used to think
about myopia as an optical defect now we
think about it much more as disease in
the earlier a child becomes myopic the
more serious their myopia can become and
the greater the risk of debilitating
conditions which means it's important to
intervene as early as possible so what
does that look like
for those who start to develop myopia
there's treatment first are multifocal
soft contacts and glasses they make
peripheral vision intentionally blurry
which appears to slow the progression of
myopia then there's orthoceratology or
Ortho K lenses hard contact lenses worn
only at night that reshape the wear as
cornea while they sleep so that they can
see at a distance during the day and
their atropine eye drops low doses of a
substance that temporarily paralyzes the
eyes focusing muscles which seems to
reduce the developments of myopia but
the first line of defense is prevention
the simplest and most effective way to
prevent myopia is to get kids to spend
more time outside in Taiwan the
government introduced a nationwide
program in 2010 encouraging schools to
get students outside for two hours every
day it appears to have successfully
reversed a 40 year long increase in
myopia rates and since 2001 Singapore
has funded public education promoting
time outdoors and conducted annual
Vision screenings at schools and it
seems to be working
right now these rates may be higher than
ever but the future of myopia will only
look like this if we keep doing things
the same way and we've never been in a
better position to change
foreign
[Music]